we're doing good thanks for asking a lot
of people uh don't know we've had a
previous episodes with you so i'll link
them all in the description if you don't
know who sheikh mohan even farooq is
what are you doing check over the
wonderful work that one message
foundation is doing over on youtube
that's three words one message
foundation or type in omf um but before
we go into it i just want to say we will
do a live q a with check with monument
farooq so if you have questions you can
ask it now but we're going to start
addressing it around 30 minutes later
me bro why don't you take over
all right bismillah you know every time
a sheikh you know comes in the house
especially with man may allah bless you
bro uh everyone's already popping out
for questions
we all know that when there's like an
ocean of knowledge in front of us we
just want to take what we can but my
question first and foremost was
firstly i wanna say alhamdulillah that
the sheikh is okay and everything uh
because recently there was that i heard
about
that you guys spoke about omf and
everything that for a while you couldn't
for legal reasons and everything but
just a quick summary of what happened
um so alhamdulillah
we by the will of allah we go out there
and do our tawa we do our thing and it's
been going on and you know we have
haters and
you know it's it's okay that's the way
the world works right
and
uh we had a situation uh
before i even mentioned the situation i
mean the
we had we had threats before right like
we had people put notes and uh whatever
that uh that that uh what's that blob of
a person what is that something plus
whatever whatever it is uh that that
thing was
they encourage it right they mock it
like if there's threats against
non-muslims oh suddenly there's like
every muslims guilty of it but when
their threats against muslims when we
get you know you know people scratching
cars or putting notes or whatever they
mock it because
no those people don't really care about
muslims they don't care about the life
of a muslim or the protection of a
muslim um they're just there to hate on
islam so they kind of encourage it so we
had
this kind of environment and and that
was started to grow alhamdulillah as
it's been growing and and you get haters
you get all this kind of stuff
and we had a situation with a guy and
this guy uh
you know subhanallah uh we know who he
is it's not it's not like somebody
it's not like some guy just went nuts on
the street and just was attacking people
no it was targeted um and there was some
background to it uh he
the same person pulled out a knife on
a
a child actually a young man at the
masjid uh at fajr salaam the next day
that that night we had an event
uh i wasn't there when the incident had
happened but when i heard about it
uh we wanted to be careful so we reached
out to the police because you know
usually we take care of our own stuff
alhamdulillah
but um
but you know sometimes then brothers are
like oh you need to take care make sure
you use the suburb and all this stuff so
uh there's a community liaison guy from
the police he came out
and that night was good the next day
subhanallah
as i was
going to the park i started to think
about this as a panel i wonder if they
try something here and say
and we were just giving dawa and you can
see the video or just regular day of
da'wah and then this guy comes and he
starts
to make threats uh we we've released a
longer version which is like all the
video that we have
uh and we did like a commentary on it
too it's on the omf channel so he he
took out a it's like a metal baton
looking thing and he started making
threats and he was hitting so i was
giving dawah to this panel that's a
really strange uh
couple who were these hardcore
christians but they believed that jesus
came back as a korean man
yeah
at least he can barbecue so um anyway so
he was uh
while i was talking to them you know
like like they're kind of a strange
thing but we were making progress like i
was trying to explain to them about the
bible and things then i hear this guy
and he's cussing and he's using like
he's making fun of uh like he's making
fun of allah he's making fun of salah
he's making fun of muslims
hi guys it's it's bothering me but like
i really want to focus on that well so i
told some brothers hey go talk to him
alhamdulillah we got good brothers out
there so they went and they they tried
to talk to him calmly and then he pulled
out a knife on
the brothers and he was you know
swinging around now the camera was on me
at this time but some brothers they did
get some cell phone footage of it um
then
it got to a point that even that couple
was like like this guy's crazy like they
could hear him i mean obviously so when
when they left then like by that time um
for soon as it is so like my
my brain was just done so i i just
rushed at him and subhanallah was
unarmed i mean none of us were carrying
any weaponry or anything like that but i
just rushed at him and he was like i'm
gonna effing like he was saying the word
obviously but nothing hit you and i was
like just hit me then like i was
thinking subhanallah like if he's going
to attack the other muslims might as
well just hit me first i was like hit me
then i was like you're not going to do
anything you know so i rushed at him and
the coward that these uh hopes are he
ran right he ran away
and
i ran at him and he ran away when i
started walking back and this if you see
the video i'm was behind that uh the
little arches because he was like
hitting the metal bars and stuff like
you know trying to make noise when i'm
walking back he takes out the knife he
starts to rush at me
so i hear like i you know i mean i was
raising the hood so my ears are always
open right so you know i hear these
steps coming at me so i turn right
around and then i rush at him again he's
got a knife and he runs away
and this is an important lesson for the
muslim ummah look
the nusra of allah is there
i guess we use the means alhamdulillah
but remember allah puts a rob allah puts
a honor on a muslim
that when you stand with tawakkul
even a stronger or a better equipped
enemy would be afraid of you
right so i ran back at him and
subhanallah he ran away again like the
coward that he is
and now when i'm walking back he tries
it one more time then one more time i
turn around then he runs and then khalas
i come back
and uh and he's still blabbing on and
then
the you know subhanallah like when we're
there even if the debate gets a little
loud from our side the police is there
right away but this guy was like yelling
and screaming and people like
non-muslims were telling them go home
like you can hear in the video and they
were telling him leave him alone and
but there was no security i don't know
where the police was that day so
anyway by the time we got back
uh after all of this he was still going
on
finally i see the uh park security which
is one of the types of police we have
there him coming and as soon as this guy
sees that he he takes off right
so he takes off
and then we thought about like going
trying to catch him whatever but then
we're like we're trying to give that out
so we just went back to giving dawah
like we didn't like pack up and go home
or something we just went back to giving
dawah like hamdulillah there's videos of
us afterwards after that giving dawah
and then the regular police department
came and and subhanallah they caught
them you know that day they they you
know
as the some non-muslims had actually
called it in and they had given a
description so when he was uh quite a
like you know maybe
i don't know three four hundred feet
away they they saw the description they
matched it they got him and they found
the weapons on him he had the knife he
had the metal baton um
you know so they they got him and they
brought him uh close to where we were so
so kind of like i don't even call the
police like i personally didn't even i
was like let's just go back to tawa but
you know other people at the park
subhanallah had seen it
and then you know we had to sit down
with the police we
we
had an interesting background i mean
obviously we had known who he was
because he had come to the masjid he had
made the threats and all that
but they looked into his background and
there was some interesting stuff that
came up that we didn't know about and
they were trying the police i mean the
hate crime division had gotten involved
and they found that he had done a
similar kind of intimidation for another
group out there at the park before and
before that he had some ties to some
christian groups um quite a few years
back
um so that's originally they were
telling us like you know keep keep this
a little bit
um
on the hush so we can try to figure out
if we can match any phone numbers to
some people some other people that had
come out to the park if you know what i
mean
some things were found but not enough to
really move forward with so uh but the
person did get arrested he got a felony
and uh
you know alhamdulillah we're still out
there doing our thing so
um
the reason i asked about this initially
i know i'm aware that you made it you
actually watched it i think it was
amazing masha'allah so if you guys
didn't see you want more in depth
inshallah go check out the video on omf
but
when i watch it i was amazed because
there's almost this narrative and i
think everyone here can attest with it
there's almost this narrative with the
muslims that we need to be passive we
need to be so peaceful that even though
we're targeted people we're a targeted
minority in a lot of places and people
come at us we need to kind of you know
lay down with our neck on the floor
ready
kind of for the chopping block and uh
the question is
you're saying no already masha allah
that's that's
i don't know i don't know i mean i i
feel what you're saying and i hear it
nowadays i don't know what book these
muslim imams are reading but that's not
the quran that's not the hadith that's
not the way of the salaf that's not the
way of rasulullah
we're not turning any other cheeks
that just it's just not good
if we had become scared if we had
you know back down
not only would this person would have
done more
but i guarantee you more people like him
would have taken initiative
right
look
nowadays and i'm gonna
be a little
yeah okay
we see videos right of of our sisters
and others being harassed and all this
and people are like so proud of this oh
this is
where the men
no
when people think they can bully you
like i don't you all went to high school
right
when people think they can bully you and
all you're going to do is cry about it
they're going to bully you more
but the first bully that gets a black
eye
nobody's going to bully you after that
about the um
if everyone's you know aware about the
issue in india then i won't spend too
long talking about it but they're trying
to ban hijab they stopped young muslim
women from going to school because yeah
and all of that when the video of that
muslim sister may allah bless her you
know standing up against those i guess
hindu nationalists and everything
and fighting basically for her like
hijab and kind of going out literally
like dozens of men yelling at them and
stuff
one guy died um
i i don't want to get too much in that
particular situation we can discuss that
but
but but i mean in general
i see videos of muslim women whether
it's in france whether it's in whatever
uh
being harassed and some of them
masha'allah may allah bless them i mean
they're brave they're strong
may allah bless our sisters and protect
them but
what are the men
i mean oh no
when you look at
the question which i'll answer as well
when we look at uh the meccan period for
example and how the sahaba were attacked
right
when when you had people like
when you had hamza bin abdullah
you think they got punked by the people
of makkah no they stood they they they
stood up for what they are you think
rasulullah
was just putting his head down no
they stood there were people like yasa
radhian who they didn't have the ability
that became shohada and even they they
did it with braveness they didn't go and
beg the quraish right
when we have a muslim ummah that is 1.8
billion strong 2 billion according to
some estimates right when you have a
muslim ummah that has
so many resources we can't be hiding
behind the meccan period we need to
stand look i'm here in san diego i'm
raised in san diego i'm from san diego
right
when i was in middle school when i was
in high school when i was you know
younger and all that kind of stuff right
and and somebody uh looked at me wrong
right and i i remember those days i'd be
like what are you looking at
what
you know i mean i was never a punk to
begin with right i used to dress i mean
allah forgive us for the past i used to
dress with like dickies and pendletons
and all that and if somebody asked you
what what you're wearing or why you
wouldn't be like what you're talking to
me
right i didn't take it back then you
think i'm going to take it as a muslim
never
allah subhanahu ta'ala gives us
allah gives us
protects us and allah sees everything
every hardship that people go through
allah knows about it sometimes it's good
for you sometimes it's a terbia for you
sometimes an ajar for you sometimes a
teschia for you sometimes it's to raise
your ranks all of that but don't think
that allah doesn't see you right
so if somebody's going to step to us i
don't care who it is right and this is
not the first time this kind of thing
has happened you can see the other guy
who was trying to get on my face and all
that right look we're polite we're
muslims we have good manners we're
patient we're giving dawah we're trying
to benefit people we live within the
laws all that kind of stuff but
we are not ones to be messed with and
and let the world know that right so
that so that the next bully the next guy
two things will think twice right
uh subhanallah
even if you look at uh any how um
in his
time in mecca was and how when how his
islam and i mean there are some weak
directions some strong you can look we
have a series in the majority channel
that goes over his life so you can see
about that but
he always lives with isa and it was
honor rasool
he was very strong people think of
bakker as being like a skinny man or
something but his his personality that's
why i called him abu bakr a bucket is a
strong
young camel right so his personality was
very strong that's the sahaba they they
live with strength
and others that were that were forced
in a torture situation where they had no
ability yes i we understand their their
patience but it's not like they they
they gave into that
right it's not like they just went in
and begged uh omaya or somebody a rollie
they were like oh please help us no
i mean this is this is where muslims
today have just uh fallen for this
victim uh narrative like you know they
they love the tears of sympathy and all
that and look we appreciate all the
non-muslims that stood with us and uh we
appreciate all of that but
we need
we're men and we're going to stand for
the huck and otherwise i don't know what
are the beards and all that do for you
if you don't if you don't stand like a
man it's just show then right
i won't talk about the situation but i
got a dm kind of response to all of that
and one brother he who's really he had
this narrative of like what she was
doing was haram and i'm like what bro
you're focused on the wrong thing here
you're mad about a sister standing up
and being strong like where where's your
father where's your brother where are
the muslim men you know in the area
where the fight around the world and
it really shocked me that he kind of had
that
thought that thinking process and if you
look at the meccan period
like
yes they they had like a tribal society
to begin with so a lot of the muslims a
lot of the people they were already
protected
by their tribes so they didn't have this
hierarchical kind of structure we have
today where there's a government police
and all that they had tribes so the
muslims in a way they were protected and
that's why they couldn't just completely
exterminate the muslims they tried but
why are we focusing on the meccan stage
what happened when allah spent
the ayah saying to go kill the the you
know combat disbelievers they went and
they fought and they won muhammad
so why are we focusing on
you know the first
few years
even in makkah you look at um
you look at hamza and they were they
were strong you look at rasulullah
you look at others when
when they stood they give dawah they
didn't they didn't just cower and change
their names and try to hide their
identity you know
we have people today and i'll tell you
something funny um
this is uh
interesting outcome of a lot of this
stuff right
um we have and i can't tell you too much
but i mean i'll tell you where you get
the gist right there's a 15 year old
and this person was uh or is in a
hardcore christian
conservative
david wood following kind of family
and
subhanallah when the first time uh
hammer time came out they
they watched the video the whole family
like they were on a big screen all this
stuff right
and when they when they saw what
happened i mean they were mentioning
themselves the father got so upset threw
his beer cans at the tv which great
father they were sitting there
so
uh got upset right
and then
they were like well i started watching
all your videos after that one after the
after after the other and then they
contacted omf they emailed us and they
were like hey i want to become muslim
but you know my school's a christian
school my family is like this
and subhanallah they accepted islam
and took the shahada still in secret
right
15 year old living in a household uh any
with that kind of environment it's
difficult
uh especially females and stuff it's not
easy
for them to then just be like okay i'm
gonna wear hijab and all that and that's
understandable like that's an
understandable situation
there are about
150 to 200 million muslims in india
depending on estimates that you take
right roughly about half of those are
men um india was ruled by muslims for a
good amount of their history um you know
many of their
uh hollywood style
bollywood actors are supposedly by name
muslim there are muslim congress people
there whatever senators i don't know
what they have they're parliamentarians
they have all this stuff
and these poor sisters are left there
defending themselves and then all these
guys want to talk about you know
this and that like look
where's your primary responsibility here
protecting your family protecting your
honor protecting your
allah mustang may allah protect us man
i mean i mean i mean i feel like a lot
of men they they blur the lines between
rights and responsibilities because they
lack knowledge so simply put how would
you summarize the main roles and
responsibilities that men have
as
fathers brothers
husbands in general
that's a deep subject you know i'm gonna
summarize it but no doubt first and
foremost
um to be leaders right to be those that
guide the family to be those who
give serbia to give the upbringing to
the family
and everybody's gonna have shortcomings
we don't expect every man to be perfect
we don't expect every woman to be
perfect but men have this responsibility
that they they set the rights and left
they say okay this is
this is our limit we're not going to
pass this limit you know this is our
limit on the other side you know giving
that that'll be a explaining teaching
um being
uh supportive being uh you know being
responsible right
leadership is not about
just being power hungry leadership's
about responsibility meaning um
you know they say the captain goes down
with the ship right
what is the meaning of that statement in
america or in english
is that that captain is going to be
responsible for the safety of everybody
else so he makes sure everybody if the
ship is sinking he's making sure that
everybody gets off safe right uh we say
the buck stops here you know in english
you know meaning the responsibility
stops there if you have a leader of a
organization and the organization
doesn't do well he can't just come on tv
and be like
it was the who's the worker guys they
were not doing well you know no then in
the end he asked he takes the cut he
takes he resigns you know like police
departments if something happens and you
see the chief will go and be like
i'm gonna take this it's not that the
police chief did it but he's responsible
right so a muslim man should be
responsible for the household right so
now if you
if your wife is having to go out there
and and work and and and you know
struggle because you're sitting around
the house doing nothing you are not
fulfilling your responsibility don't
come home and be like yo you know i just
came back from the coffee shop and now
go cook me something and clean this and
do that look look you you are not doing
your job right but when you're a man
when you are when you are like i'm going
to bring the risk by the will of allah
i'm going to go out there to the best of
my i'm going to work i'm going to try
now sometimes and even in situations
like that the woman may have to work
because the world the way the world
works i understand but
it should only be in a necessity a woman
shouldn't have to go out right a man
should be there to to to lead that
household
and when that man is is there
one of the core responsibilities that he
has to the best of his ability like i
said um is to be a protector
right
people don't understand the depth of
this meaning you are the caretakers
right so why are muslim women not
allowed to travel more than a certain
distance without a mahram why is it that
these things why because a man and this
is something i mean i know like people
don't want to talk about this and i'm
sorry guys you know i i can't not be
real so that's just the way i am right
uh
i know people don't want to talk about
this but but this is psychology this is
reality this is fitra this is the way in
san is
if you have a woman and and i don't care
if she's like masha'allah
6'5 and you know just straight cut ufc
fighting style right
but she walks down the street alone you
will see predators just eyeing her right
and that's wrong
it shouldn't be that way but it is just
the world we live in it's reality right
she could have like a 10 year old or a
12 year old or a 14 year old
let's say let's say a a 15 year old
skinny boy with her
and psychologically they'll just be like
oh somebody's with her all right let's
wait
and and this is a strange psychology but
that's how people work
right so
you know if you if you see all these and
this is reality and people want to brush
under the carpet or whatever but go look
up stats you see women whose cars break
down um you know on interstates where
there's nobody around and many of them
any uh may allah protect all
our sisters but many of them are raped
many of them are harmed many of them are
uh you know taken advantage of by
horrible
excuses for human beings these rapists
and stuff right
but if you look at those studies even if
they have like a little kid like a male
boy next with them you'll see those
stats statistically go look it up right
so this means men have that
responsibility too to make sure our
women are you know who are
our valued uh members of our families
are safe right
on top of that
making sure that there is an islamic
environment you know what the oath is
one of the types of people that allah
will not look at on the day of judgment
somebody who doesn't have rira for their
women who's not worried about their
hijab was not worried about their uh any
sticking to the rules and regulations
that allah has pertained but
many men unfortunately they are such bad
examples themselves right
that how can they
say
to a woman oh you need to make sure
you're wearing hijab and this and that
when they're out there hitting the club
themselves when they're out there
drinking when they're doing things that
they know their haram so
the last thing i want to say about this
is also set a good islamic example
for your wife for your kids this is from
the responsibilities of the husband
alhamdulillah
so to recap leader provisioner sustainer
protector
uh clock having good example leading by
example these are all wonderful things
um my next question before i pass it on
to angel um and it'll be my last one for
now is
uh if you had to balance you know
between
technique in terms of self defense um
and let's say this was your son or this
was your cousin or or a man that's you
know i'm not gonna get me in trouble
today man
yeah so so if if they wanna know you
know uh technique or more of just having
that inner that willpower that inner
wolf inside you how do you blur the line
between the two because it does get
blurry right so what do you prioritize
so i i would say it's not an either or i
think those have to work hand in hand
right you could have
rage and willpower but if you don't know
how to box if you don't know how to take
a punch if you don't know how to block a
punch if you don't know how to throw a
kick or all that kind of stuff
you might have a lot of like
zeo but then the somebody who's a
trained fighter will just use that
against you right like when i was in
high school if i saw somebody just
trying to come at me like straight like
that first thing i would do just get out
the way and kick them or something just
let them fall right and then once
underground it's over after that right
uh unless you're really good at jujitsu
maybe i don't know but um right so
but in high school if you went to the
floor and i was still standing that
fight's over man you're going to be like
i never i told you guys you're going to
be in trouble today man all right so uh
so that's the first thing
i think it should be a balance right
like i think you should have lira i
think you should have that manly hood
that honor that a muslim should have
that the sahaba had that rasulullah
and at the same time
i think everybody
should
learn some
uh level of martial arts because
first thing i mean i'm just gonna try to
get myself not so much in trouble um
just to stay in shape right like you
know get some cardio with it
right so you know you just want to
be healthy right that's that's good
um
right
but to be uh
um
i i'm a long-term practitioner of the
pashtun martial arts i don't know if
you've ever heard of it
no could you uh elaborate on that it's
called ching ching pao
okay never you guys ever heard ching
ching
uh next question
all right honor bro go in
hi
hey
how are you
good to be honest
so question that i have for you man why
do you think that most
if well i can't say all because it's not
all the muslim men but most of the
muslim men have become
[Music]
i'm just so soft
all right so more getting myself in
trouble um
i i think first thing i don't think it's
it's exclusive to muslim men
i think men in general have become
um
not just soft but pathetic you know
and i think it's not a coincidence i i
mean i'm not a conspiracy theorist he
got theory guy but i'm gonna i'm gonna
throw this out right
um if you look at
role models for men
in the
40s 50s i don't know back in those days
you had like cowboys john
wayne or whatever
whatever those actors may be like
whatever at home but the the what they
portrayed were these strong
you know if you look at the leave it to
beaver show kind of things the father
was intelligent he was
strong he was supportive he was you
stood up you had
um
you know you had all these kinds of
good qualities you could say being
presented in the father
and then you had a time where hollywood
made fathers into morons and two
weaklings into
um
you say that sade how about man i'm
telling you
all right
so
i i mean as much as i'd even want to
control myself i'm just not that guy so
we're gonna we're gonna hear it anyway
um
you had the likes of uh i don't know if
you guys are young mashallah but there
was that show called married with
children you had this guy bundy or dead
bundy oh something bundy i don't know
um and he was he was he was a [ __ ] he
was a fool he was uh he had no leader he
didn't care about any of that stuff he
was he was always wrong you know and you
had the simpsons you had homer homer was
an idiot and marge was always right and
you had
uh after then and i kind of when i
stopped
most of that tv stuff by the later time
but you had like the family guy and
american dad and all these
really pathetic
bad examples being put forward
so al bundy yeah exactly ted wendy's a
serial killer never mind
um
whatever it's bundys yeah um right
so
you had
i think
there was a
effort
to try to
uh
de-masculine men right um and and and
and again i'm not a conspiracy seriously
guy but but but put it to the test
look at the
hollywood slash tv
uh male figures back in the 40s and 50s
and 30s or whatever and going forward
and then you'll see like i don't know i
don't know i mean i don't know what year
exactly you can make that change but you
will see
a change where they all started being
very weak right um fools and
irresponsible right and and that stuff
is programming your brains right um on
top of that
on top of that you had
you had some movements that
and they might have been
movements that were
originally
uh
people with sincere intent i mean
i don't know right but you had the
feminist movements and all these kinds
of things
but
but it ended up
harming
those that they were trying to protect
right uh i mean like you see the metoo
movement and and again
i'm all
about uh protecting women and believing
women and i'm against this whole
uh you know what what goes on in
hollywood
but
again the way they went about it ended
up harming women and you can see the
studies that have been done where now
male bosses are uncomfortable
even
you know promoting females because
they're afraid that if she gets into
that situation there something might be
taken the wrong way and and so so it
ended up just harming women further
instead of saying hey
maybe we shouldn't have halwa we
shouldn't have men and women being alone
maybe we shouldn't have where movie
directors are picking
14 year olds and trying to get them into
careers and all this stuff that with
hijab and islam those things would be
protected to begin with instead of going
about it the right way you go about the
wrong way so feminists many of them they
did the same thing instead of saying hey
women should be dignified and honored
and so on as islam says and men should
be responsible and caring and instead of
that it was just like men and women are
the same right
and okay well
to be honest i mean equal
as equally responsible in front of allah
yes
equally important for humanity yes
in many ways
the mother is more important she's given
a greater status
in islam
so everybody has its own but not the
same
we're not the same it's just i'm sorry
biologically psychologically you can go
any whether you want to look at a
religious text or you just want to look
at uh nature we're not the same and
until we realize that and and and
understand that and know what is the
natural role of a man and that of a
woman and how to properly work together
for a beneficial society
it's not going to work right so i think
a lot of that
changed the mindset of men and muslim
men unfortunately were a victim to that
um having said that another aspect that
affected muslim men is the fact that um
after 9 11 and stuff the whole community
was just very apologetic and pathetic
and instead of being like you know what
man that had nothing like i condemn it
whatever
you know but it got nothing to do with
me like you know when when when january
was a january 6 when they attacked the
capital you know right what was it
january 3rd 6th whatever um when
you know when those
trump guys stormed the white house or
whatever and killed police officers and
all that right
i didn't go to my white neighbors and be
like hey
so
what do you guys have to apologize about
today you know no they had trump flags
or whatever they didn't come and say hey
we're sorry for that january 6th yeah
right
no they were like well we weren't there
so what's i got to do with us right so
i had nothing to do with 9 11. so why
should i apologize right i condemn all
terrorism all
whether by muslims or non-muslims if you
kill innocent people that's against
islam and we as muslims condemn that but
we don't need to apologize for anybody
else right
and and that that atmosphere kind of
covered the muslim community not just in
america but even abroad and i think that
also i mean everybody's just afraid
the last thing i'll say
is
the lack of taqwa
i mean i know like that might not
connect in people's minds right away but
that's a part of it right when you fear
allah and you love allah and you know
allah sees you and you're afraid of the
disobedience of allah a very deep term
then you don't care what people say you
do what allah orders and what the
prophet isaiah showed right
but when you don't then you're just
trying to get be liked by people you're
worried about people liking you and in
trying to get people to like you you
give up your responsibilities right
if i
today
um
gave up the beard and gave up
uh
saying what i say
uh i would get many more opportunities
by mainstream muslim organizations to
become known right but i'm never going
to do that because what's the point
and i ask allah for istahama that if i
stay on the quran and on the sunnah and
allah is pleased with me i would be more
than happy dying alone with nobody
knowing my name alhamdulillah
when the muslims stand on that then you
will see a lot of these problems
corrected
[Music]
it's long answer sorry
no no that's a good answer
and today i want to add on
uh first a question
that's a believer
depending on the arabic structure would
be many believers but yeah you're right
it's a believer
okay okay
so do you think that
these men who
are soft because of the environment
because of everything that's going on
and they're solid because they like the
taco and everything
um do you think that's
i don't want to say an issue with akita
because i'm sure you know they still
have the proper beliefs
and all that but it's more so like
you have the true believer who
you know they they truly understand that
this life is just temporary and it's is
nothing you know it really is nothing
and that
you know all sustenance comes from allah
everything comes from allah
health everything everything comes from
allah so
if they are presented with something
they are willing to
give it all up for the sake of allah
right like that would be a true believer
would it not be and then it raises the
question as i okay these men
who they're presented with something
right allah presents them with this uh
this test if you will
like and they back down because
psychologically
whatever it is they mentally they got
something going on so would it then be
that this person is not really
a believer because they are not having
that full
submission you know
uh i tried to leave
that kind of a judgment to allah
right
all i can say is that they are lacking
in fulfilling their
responsibilities right
who is the man who is
who is a muslim who is more sin who is
at what level
i'll leave that because allah knows the
hearts right i don't know the hearts
but as a muslim we are responsible
for
fulfilling responsibilities in judging
whether they're being done right some
people say oh only allah can judge you
only allah can judge your hearts only
allah can judge your intention only
allah knows what's what your true intent
was but
there is judgment in dunya that's why we
have judges that's why you islamic
courts that's why we have
we give haqqam right
i will say that that any man who is
doesn't have zera to protect their
family and to stand up and be the best
role model they can and again everybody
will have shortcomings but to the best
of their ability
is is lacking in fulfilling the rights
that are due upon him
right whether he's a movement or not
we'll leave that to allah
hmm
y'all have any other questions
bro that was a really good question yeah
i was gonna i was gonna ask that myself
because it's very hard to concern but at
the end of the day
it's up to allah it's not up to us but
we can advise we can lead by example
that's all we can do i do have one last
question before we start doing the live
q a insha allah
and i want to say anyone that made it
this far if you did spam the live chat
right i know who you guys are i could
see i could see all the names and stuff
too
uh kind requests just do an order of
importance right we're gonna try to give
everyone a minimum of one uh question
that we'll answer uh shack will answer
and if we have more time then you can
answer more
but if you had like if you give like a
lot of questions i'm just going to pick
one randomly out of it
inshallah and uh
jeffy ready i'll ask my question
i'm ready
okay so my last question before we do
the q a
is
let's say you have a son right
and you notice that you're trying to
make
you know you're trying to make progress
with them right
you know we're not going to make this
personal you know nothing just in
general hypothetical
son you're trying to get at him you're
trying to do everything you can um maybe
you're even homeschooling him but i
don't know the culture that we're living
i am you know yeah
maybe even hopefully and the culture
that we live in bro it just it just it's
almost like whatever work you do society
just kind of you know reverts to that in
a way addresses that in a way
and you're at a point where it's like
you're trying to guide them you're
trying to do your best for your son but
it's just not happening
and you're kind of in a fork in the road
now and this is his son you can't you're
gonna be questioned by allah if you give
up on your son
so how would you tackle this this
situation
that's a great question and i have two
sons may allah protect them i have two
daughters may allah protect them
you can never give up on family
uh
that's your family that's your kids
that's your
dna that's your blood that's your
responsibility that you
to any male can
um impregnate a woman but only a man can
father a child right
so part of that is you you don't give up
there is no like i tried let it go no
you also can't
guide anybody guidance is from allah
your responsibility is to
set a good example to the best of your
ability and again
every one of us myself before anybody
else has shortcomings
but to set a good example to teach them
islam
to encourage them towards their salah
and siam and
very important to relate to them like i
joke with my kids and sometimes people
tell me like oh don't don't be so you
know
friendly with your kids but my kids are
i mean alhamdulillah we're we're friends
in a way i mean i'm not trying to be
their friend you know i'm not trying to
be like oh i want to be cool no i'm
already cool so i don't need to try but
but
but i mean you know
they can talk to me right like you know
yes alhamdulillah i have my own
responsibilities but you know they're
going through something i've always made
it that they can talk to me i always
take their opinions and things but
sometimes i have to make decisions
they're not going to like but i have to
do that as a father that's my job
and i'm not going to care whether they
like me or not because
that's not what i'm trying to do i'm not
trying to win a popularity contest
so when you have that relationship when
you have that communication when you
have conveyed the importance of what it
means to be a muslim and the akhira and
judgment and standing in front of allah
and the
hereafter and all of that
then
you make dua for them you ask allah to
guide them you do your best if they are
old enough that they are not going to
listen to you
what can you do right but i would never
i would never say give up on that
because you don't know i mean i know
brothers
that were religious good kids and they
went through like a bad phase and
10 years they were out
and then they came back to it you know
they remembered what their father or
their mother or their you know
grandfather told them as a kid and when
life
life reminds you
you know like
sometimes we get this question why is
there suffering in the world and there's
many answers there's a video coming up
on the one message foundation we
answer this question at the park but
one of the aspects of it is it's a
reminder right if you had no suffering
you would almost all of us would just
get lost in this dunya
we would just be lost in our desires
where everybody has different desires
but we would just be lost but when we
have suffering we realize hey
this world wasn't meant forever and many
times that's a check so sometimes a kid
you know allah protect all our children
but he might go to the wrong path
and then
some suffering comes
and that reminds him and they'll come
back and if you cut off relations
then where will they go to for guidance
right so i would say you should always
be there for them
if they want you to help them in haram
never help people in harambe they're
like hey bye
dad buy me a house and reba or hey
buy alcohol for me then obviously and
you you cannot do that but
you should always be
a resource for them as long as you're
alive where if they want to turn back or
if they want to learn or they have a
question or they have a problem they
should be able to go to you as a parent
and discuss it with you and you should
be supportive of that
i want to say this right now i don't
want anyone taking words out of my mouth
but it's kind of the way that
we have a relationship with allah
like allah allah is never going to raise
in rank because of us doing better and
trying to please allah
for allah and allah is not going to go
down if we do you know you get what i
mean so at the end of the day allah is
always unchanged but allah always wants
us to good allah doesn't need us to do
good but allah always wants the best for
us and uh why why should we not want the
best for us ourselves right and allah is
always there ready to forgive us ready
to guide us all we have to do is ask
right and at the end of the day i feel
like having that type of you know i
don't mean this in a weird comparison to
allah or anything but just having that
trait that attribute or just i'm always
there for you i'm not gonna you know
bend over backwards to kind of guide you
but at the end of the day like i'm
always here for you if you need it yeah
and it's you know i don't need you to do
that you should want to do that yourself
but i'm always ready to help you you
know
there is a hadith
and my children when they were very
young like
my sons maybe we're like
three or four years old i had them
memorize this hadith
um which is whoever doesn't show mercy
will not be shown mercy
so to your point you know if you are not
going to be merciful towards your
children or if you're not going to be
merciful towards the weak and so on then
your relationship with allah will be
affected why would allah then show you
mercy when allah is always there for you
when you you can always make tawbah
uh i like milk tea
i usually don't read the comments but
i'm reading them today
all right okay i don't want to take too
long get to the questions all right
all right so uh first comment
so ben writes i want to come to see you
before ramadan you know what that's not
actually the question that i wanted to
display
that's okay
you know uh
this one from ben so when i check i
reverted back to islam on november 18th
last year i watched the video of yours
called this should make you cry the bit
when you said who else was it made for
shook me to my core subhanallah
subhanallah reward you and protect you
brother uh
you're welcome to see us anytime i would
just make sure uh i do have some travel
that's gonna be coming up we're gonna be
going up to canada uh for some tawa
stuff and i think cleveland and
somewhere else i'm not sure is that but
i would just say hey check the channel
uh the brother who runs the twitter
account also usually posts uh my travels
and things to make sure you don't come
out here and i'm not here because i
would feel very sad
uh
but yeah
anytime you want to come and become
you're more than welcome uh having
tattoos don't worry about it you know um
you know subhanallah
whatever happened before islam nobody
should be worried about and nobody
should be judged for if anybody's going
to judge you for that then don't care
what they think anyway um
allah does not hold you accountable for
what you did before islam in fact as we
see in some of the hadith you will be
like a newborn baby or fresh slade other
hadith even mentioned that your passions
return to good deeds and so on
so uh you know i mean if if you're
uncomfortable wear long sleeve shirts or
whatever um you know i i don't i usually
wear long sleeves i don't like wearing
t-shirts but that's just personal um
right but
even if you do and if somebody somebody
says something you know just be
be polite and be like yeah brother you
know i'm new in islam this was before
islam follows
uh you know whatever is past that don't
worry about people um may allah reward
you for you accepted islam that's
amazing
uh regarding that video in other videos
you know we ask allah to guide us uh
sometimes myself you know you
you you make
uh
any
i read an ayah or a hadith or i listen
to a lecture and sometimes it just
shakes me like myself you know just
you know and then you you look at
the fact that there is a jahannam and
there is a fire and and you know that
that that this was made
to be filled with people
and then
you know you you you become heedless how
we don't have any guarantees this is
this is insane this is not that that
fake uh salesman pitch of christians
where you're like oh yeah you're saved
yeah don't matter whatever
um
so
it should never
hamper us from being
uh productive
but it should always keep us on our toes
meaning we should always be making dua
we should always be asking allah to make
a steadfast we should always be
begging allah that you know we
we don't slit
being guided is a great bounty of allah
but having steadfastness upon the
guidance
that that is uh something you should
always be asking allah for
so we ask allah to protect us and
keep us on the right path and look
forward to meeting our brother in person
inshallah i mean chef he said you're
coming to canada right
uh i am i'm not sure where it's like a
crazy trip it's like some
um it's like every day i'm gonna be in a
different city or something so
bro you know you know me and the romney
live in canada right
i'm going to come see you guys in a
while where we can just hang out one of
these days man inshallah let's make up
our next question
um
before you before you bring that
question and let me slide in
with the uh tattoos
should one have higher and should one
cover up
you know yes allah forgives
but at the same time like
uh you know tattooing in and of itself
is a sin if
you know you're a muslim and you get a
tattoo
i'm not yes it was forgiven but
it's you know it's on us forever
i i understand and i think it's
especially if the tattoo is something
that like you know some brothers get
things that are obscene or some things
that are foolish
i think it's good to have haya and cover
it
i just don't want people to think they
should be
ashamed of something they did in the
past you know um it was what it was when
a person didn't know better so hello
we don't judge them on that but you know
i don't think you should be flexing it
either right i don't think she'll be
going too much to be like oh
check it out my website right so uh
you know uh find that balance you know
okay
all right so is it okay for a girl to
take photos wearing regular hijab
showing face only for her and other
women to see my mom gets angry when i
don't take photos with her so please
give dalil i can show her inshallah
excellent um
first and foremost
um
may allah protect you and may allah
increase you in your goodness and may
allah make increase your
your shyness because it's good to see
the younger generation
having more uh a concern than some of
the older generation and we see it a lot
but it always makes me very happy
um
secondly to take pictures uh regular
hijab is kind of an interesting term and
let me and i understand what she meant
but let me let me clarify a couple of
things hijab
is the concept of of concealment right
meaning allah has hijab from us
arabic language would be when something
is hidden you cannot see right
we take hijab to mean like the
scarf and then we take nikob to be the
front but those terms are incorrect uh
the
is what sits on the head the cloth that
sits on the head in arabic it's called
it's
so
hijab would actually be when the woman
is the most cover when you're more
covered where everything you possibly
can cover like the height of nearby
where an eye and according to some of
the then that meaning the two eyes would
be seen for the path
this would be a proper understanding of
hijab
um but to take pictures with the face
showing um depending on and there is two
opinions amongst islam i personally take
the opinion that the face is
obligated to cover but i don't force it
on others because we respect
but even the ones that take that the
face is not obligated to be covered uh
would take that to post pictures
today
is not permissible and i'll tell you why
because
i know how social media works and i know
how the internet works and i'm sure many
of you do too there's nothing private on
the internet
this is this is a fallacy you know when
you post a picture
um
i don't care if it's on whatsapp i don't
care if it's on some secure server i
don't care um let's say i post a picture
um
of
and i'm gonna leave the sisters i'm
gonna say me like let's say me
in
uh shorts that only cover my aura only
from my navel to my knee right
obviously uh my heart was covered but i
wouldn't want that picture going out and
i say hey brothers uh you guys are my
friends i'm gonna post it but i don't
want anybody else looking at it but here
i wanna post it for you guys now if one
of those brothers is sitting there
looking at that on his laptop and his
wife or his sister or his daughter is
sitting there what prevents them from
seeing it right if he downloads it if he
saves it on his right this is the first
thing so now put the other situation and
that's a woman post that picture and a
sister's looking at it and her brother
or her father or her son or her cousin
or somebody like that what prevents them
from seeing it right
secondly
if you understand how the internet works
there is nothing private
facebook whatsapp they have rights to
all that that you put on there read
those little you know things you sign
when you when you when you scroll down
and hit accept
um
those guys could be looking at these
pictures right they could publish these
pictures they have been
uh
stories in the media that that people
put things on certain social media
platforms that were then seen in
commercials and they were like what is
that and then they found that they
un you know without thinking they
checked something
saying that you know it's okay to use
without even realizing and then they see
their face or their bikini clay
private picture being used somewhere
because that that was sold by the
company
so
having said all that you know don't do
it like why like what's the big deal
like you know
uh
talk to your mother tell her look uh
rasulullah sallallahu he told us that
that
the best it's a woman to be covered that
every time she goes out there is a
shaitaan that calls people towards her
so now
you see a woman may not even be going
out but if you're posting pictures
shaitan is going to be tempting people
right and if you if you look at the uh a
dilla i mean i could give i could write
a book on this but i'm just going to
give you a couple aya sharathyangha was
lost i mean she was lost out in the
desert she was at a point where she
could have died she was left behind and
when she saw a man come she covered her
face
and he subhanallah
i mean when there is no man around then
yes if i first uncovered there's no
issue but even then when she saw anybody
come close she covered her face this is
the time when she was left behind the
caravan and so on right
if you look at the another hadith of
that when she was in hajj in in
with rasulallah
with the prophet
and she said you know we would just be
with the family with those that are
maharam but when we saw the non
writers come close we would cover our
faces even in
cannot wear like a fixed niqab but with
this they would cover their faces they
didn't want a non they were so careful
all right so why would we take that
chance so we would suggest to our
sisters not to post pictures even if
you're waiting
and the the this i mean this one last
thing i'm going to
according to the majority of the
right
what can a man see
of a woman
to see if he wants to marry her right
like if a man comes to propose you can't
see the woman in you know shorts and a
t-shirt and no math allows that
um the majority of the madhav say the
face and hands
right
so that means that is what is looked at
for beauty and attraction to say hey i
can marry this person i'm good right
so
if you're posting that already
then
if somebody's interested in like serious
about marriage what are they going to
look at right i mean you're showing that
to the whole world then right um
and like i said
the internet is not private don't expect
this so may allah protect us
sam you don't like my background or what
man
i mean i mean i mean
all right
we got a few more questions i'm just
gonna try to blast through it
uh next question let's see
okay mother showed us how do you prove
the linguistic miracle from the earliest
manuscripts of the quran
when these manuscripts did not exist how
did anyone compare the quranic language
with that of the reports
interesting question
i'm not sure
where you got the point that these
manuscripts didn't exist
we actually have a video on the one
message foundation channel it's called
the preservation of the quran
it's really long it's like an hour or 15
minutes or something but i highly
recommend every dai watches it
to understand about manuscripts their
historic dating their carbon dating and
all of that um having said that even if
you were to leave the manuscripts out of
it the linguistics miracle the quran
would not be doubted because the quran
was not revealed as a book falling from
the sky it was kara quran recited so
sahaba memorized it and they recited it
the manuscripts were based on that
recitation so we do have the earliest
manuscript they've been
carbon dated by non-muslim scientists we
can prove that no problem but
even without them the linguistic miracle
the quran would stand because it was
memorized orally with the oral tradition
and we have chains
from teachers from our time all the way
to the prophet sallam that can prove we
memorize it letter by letter word by
word with each teacher crediting their
students
we have thousands if not millions of
those by the way
i mean us one expiating for breaking a
promise made to allah and you have to
fast for three consecutive days or just
three days in total this fasting during
the month of ramadan count
regarding whether the days have to be
consecutive or not there is a difference
opinions amongst the scholars of islam
uh best thing to try to do is
consecutive but if you're unable to what
i take is that you can uh give room
between them
um
and by the way that's not the first
thing you should do there is feeding
that is there is a there's a i mean
obviously freeing slaves is not going to
be a very easy option today uh but
those are all you have to look at the
order that you're looking at but anyway
um
regarding
ramadan you cannot
put a forward fast with the fault fast
meaning if you
did another or if you broke
a promise then you have an obligatory
fast and ramadan is obligatory so you
cannot count the days of ramadan towards
that
you cannot combine the niyah for the six
days of shawwal with ramadan because
that is in addition to the days of
ramadan what you could do is to fast on
mondays and thursdays and combine the
nia of fastings on mondays and thursdays
and combine that with uh the
uh obligatory makeup fasting
all right next question and guys smash
that like button if you want more videos
we'll share with monument fluke in the
future and check out the description box
now if you guys don't like it i'm going
to be offended so that's it bro if you
go to one message foundation hit
subscribe support the work insha allah
all right nabeel writes is it
permissible to wear a sports jersey with
the name of an athlete on it like kobe
or lebron
it's a good question um and i've
received this question before
i know it's very easy for some brothers
to act hardcore and just be like no
um
and and somebody else just to try to get
popular with people and say yes
uh i try to always look at the evidences
right
the the harim the haram of it is not
having a name unless the name itself is
something bad like maybe it says you
know
damien which means the devil or jesus
where you know it's a disrespect to the
prophet jesus or so on peace and blessed
be upon him so
if the name is not like kobe i don't
know i don't know what kobe means but
i'm assuming it doesn't really have a
bad meaning right
so the name itself is not an issue i
mean let's say
i go to you know a used clothes place in
afghanistan
you know and i pick up a shirt just
looks nice i throw it on and has uh i
don't know i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
date myself here bo jackson right
um
right uh
nothing wrong with that like that that's
there's no there's no delete from you
say there's tahrir there that that's
haram
where the issue comes in is
like when you try to imitate kuffar
that's the first thing right when you're
trying to play
uh a part of
trying to be like somebody who's a kafir
uh that's haram because rasulullah
sallallahu
imitates the people s he is from them
and this hadith is a reliable hadith
there is discussion on the sun but no
doubt that it is authentic so
that tells us that uh to imitate kuffar
so if you're doing it with an intention
to imitate a cafe then they would not be
permissible but if you just like a
sports team or you like the way the
shirt looks
and the meaning is not wrong
i don't see a problem with it
the other problem gets to be
is
in in our exaggeration in
um
kind of
loving a kafir right like we we have
good relationships we respect our
[Music]
relationships as neighbors
or you know co-workers and so on in the
sense that allah has ordained upon us to
be good neighbors and honest co-workers
and all of that
uh was kobe really named after japanese
beef i don't know
the first time
if it is then again
i like beef as long as
so
um you know you know
in that sense to show
over exaggerated respect for a cafe
that's also not permissible right but if
you just like the way the shirt looks i
mean and you don't have any of those
intentions and the name it in itself
doesn't have a problem i don't see a
problem with it
okay
all right jd silva wright brothers can
you ask a chef about the ruling on drop
shipping i've heard it isn't permissible
but i just wanted to clarify it
inshallah
what's drop shipping so drop shipping is
basically when you you take a product
right and you you find uh a cheap
wholesaler like china right so let's say
you want to sell uh i don't know just
for the kofar uh men's gold chains i
know we as muslims we don't do that
right
automatically obviously that would be
haram this is a bad example but just for
the sake of example let's say women's
gold chains
will chain perfect and you find uh in
china there's a company they they sell
these for like let's say 10 cents usd
right and china got a big cheap bro
china
and you start a company uh literally
called like on my name is fired so fire
jewelry or something right so you make a
premium you make it sound nice you're
not making it known that this is where
you're getting it from
you add that nice packaging and all that
or whatever you do but basically you get
that company to to basically you buy
from the company and you you have your
own website if somebody places an order
let's say sheikh man wants to buy that
for his wife right you replace that
order and what i would give her ideas
for your shipping details your name and
everything to the chinese company so
they would ship it to you directly
so there's no middleman i'm not involved
in this whatsoever i'm just upsizing it
and up pricing it from like 10 cents to
like maybe a hundred dollars you know
that's what drop shipping is yeah
i just want to say the the from what i
hear the the some of them they say it's
haram because there's a hadith i think
with the process that don't sell what
you don't own and that in that case you
don't own it
so the way you explained it
would be halal right because you bought
the product from the company the company
just shipped it so as long as it was
your property that would not that would
be halal right
but
another way that it has been explained
to me and even though i knew how it
works i asked you how it works to make
sure that's why i like to do that
is
you don't actually buy the product
you make a deal with the company to hold
a certain amount for you you didn't pay
them anything then you take orders and
as you get orders
and as they ship then you pay them
that would not be halal
right so the difference between the two
case scenarios is what you own or what
you do not own and and the hadith about
hand to hand i mean people take it
sometimes a little too literal but the
meaning of the hadith is you do not
sell what you do not own which you
cannot give right
because what happens is let's say you
make a deal with the chinese company and
now they're like yes go for it and you
take a hundred thousand dollars worth of
orders masha'allah
websites taken off you tell the company
you ship it when they ship it it ends
out that the gold is really just plastic
covered with the spray paint right or
it's something wrong
now or they don't get shipped they don't
send them right the company disappears
overnight right
now
you've taken money
and
even if you're to return the money now
it gets to be a mess right
because now
let's say you took the order six months
ago and somebody like hey you've been
sitting on my money for six months my
money's worth more now than you know all
this kind of mesquite
and that's why the shariah takes
precautions not to put you in those
situations so
if you own it like you bought it from
them and you're sure that they will
deliver
everything hands of allah but to the
best of your ability you know the
product to be correct it's your property
yes you can sell it and they can deliver
directly but if you don't own it like
you just made a deal with them and you
don't know about the product you don't
know
enough about the company and you start
sending under your name then you're
selling something you don't own that is
not permissible okay okay guys we only
have a few more minutes maybe five ten
minutes maximum so we're just gonna get
your last questions in uh sister salah
writes ruling on fasting during
pregnancy and if they need to be made up
if unable to fast during that time
sheikh for keeping it 100 good vibes
masha'allah
she's from the uk it's definitely like 2
8 1 a.m 2 a.m right now
and a lot of
our brothers and sisters out there in
the uk
they're they're the the backbones of the
tao of masha'allah
and
tayyip
um
the ruling on
fasting for the pregnant woman she is
allowed to fast and if she's able to
fast allah never puts a burden upon
anybody more than they can bear right
this is alhamdulillah the mercy of allah
and the justice of the sharia so if a
woman is pregnant but she feels good
enough that she can fast and it's not
going to harm her health or the baby's
health let's say it's the first
trimester or the second or so on then
she can fast no problem with that and
she should fast okay if she is
uh if she feels that she will
it will be difficult for her meaning
it's not going to kill her it's not
going to kill the baby it's not going to
put her in the hospital but
it's it's
she will feel weak and and maybe she the
proper nutrition will not reach the baby
in that case she has the permissibility
not too fast so it's just for her not to
fast and she will make those days up
after ramadan
if it's going to kill the baby or the
woman like let's say she's diabetic or i
mean i don't know diabetic would be
fasting but
let's say she has some other health
complications where fasting will kill
her or the baby or put their health to
serious risk then it would be haram for
her to fast
because allah does not allow people to
kill themselves
so looking at those situations now the
usual situation is that the woman is
able to fast so in that case you should
later on in the pregnancy especially
during third trimester or so on um it's
very difficult fast if it's that time
and she's unable to fast
then no problem with that you leave off
the fasting till after ramadan and you
make it up
and barakallahu kee allah bless you for
uh encouraging me to keep it 100 because
i get a lot of these you know oh don't
say this don't say that don't dress like
this
so it's always good to get some good
encouragement alhamdulillah
all right next question i will be right
i like this question
if a person spreads
either in belief or action
thinking it's the correct interpretation
of islam so they don't know
are they rewarded for their good
intentions
no
and let me explain why
first and foremost
it is obligatory
an individual obligation upon every
muslim to know the religion
right when rasulullah
told us that knowledge is arbitrary
every
muslim what knowledge is that not every
one of us has to know physics not every
one of us has to be
a scientist not every one of us has to
be a mathematician uh
contrary to desi parent's belief not
every one of us has to be a doctor uh
right so
what knowledge
rami got that one right um you got it i
saw that small crack all right um
what knowledge is obligatory upon every
muslim is to know their religion
know how to fulfill the obligations like
salah and siam
in the correct manner that's fard on us
so if you didn't take the time to learn
it and now you're promoting a bid
you will be held accountable for that
even if you didn't know this is without
why because it was followed on you to
learn right from wrong right
for you to ex why are you alive on earth
just to make money and uh sleep and eat
that i mean that's the animalistic life
just procreate and eat and hunt or you
know grace or whatever no
you have a greater purpose huh allah
says
what a beautiful i am
the one who created what
death
what is hayat
life
do you live first or die first
[Music]
how long
less powerful powerful
do you live first or die first you live
first
oh man if right now if apis is watching
this he's going to be like ah
got him
contradiction
[Laughter]
you know
the one who created death and life to
see which one of you puts forth the best
of deeds why is death mentioned before
life
because the tafseer of this ayah and you
can look in a tabari
and so on
is the word mouth death here refers to
this life
in this life oh ramy just dropped
this life was meant for death
you're meant to die so it's called mouth
in the quran
in the quran is referring here to the
life of the hereafter because that one
has no death
right
he's going to make a clip
there's literally no point based on what
you're saying to even refer to this
dunya as life
and then after that as death because all
this dunya really is then is death and
then
it's just life
exactly
this dunya is meant for death life here
is terminal right nobody's going to get
out of this alive
so
the hereafter now
is meant for ever laughter living in the
jannah may allah make us from those
not make us from those so that's why
it's called life there's no death there
right so now
wasn't even the point i was making here
right but this is the quran is so deep
right someday i want to teach to see it
like a full tipsy like three four years
to go over the quran but inshallah
what does allah say after that to see
which one of you puts forth the best of
these
the best of these not the most deeds but
the best what are the best deeds there
are two conditions given by the lemma
one that has the most sincerity ichlas
secondly in accordance with the sunnah
the prophet salallahu so for us to know
what is the right way not the bid but
the way of the sunnah this is an
obligation because that's what allah
created this life for for you to worship
allah in that way
so
no excuse for spreading vida if you're
doing something you're not sure about
ask the people of knowledge look at the
evidences easy easy easy easy
i'm going to give you a scale right now
if you're doing something
whether it's
not worldly life not if you're you know
working out in a gym or something
that that has nothing to do with the
religion right that that's
those things that are permissible right
i'm talking about if you are praying a
certain prayer on a certain day on a
certain month or if you are celebrating
a certain celebration at a certain time
of the year easy ask is it in the quran
first
if the answer is no
did the prophet saw him do it
if the answer is no did the sahabah do
it the khulafah
the answer is no alas let's get rid of
it don't do it
easy
okay alhamdulillah next question and
we're just gonna do three more questions
guys so uh if you have anything else uh
inshallah we'll be next time so how do
we know the quran is from god and why
islam is the one and only true religion
why do we have to follow the hadith and
do things exactly how usual
did and how do we know hadiths are true
i feel like this is like four questions
man
all right i'm gonna give you a brief
answer so
uh and i'm not trying to plug the
channel here i mean we have enough
subscribers i don't even care but uh we
have detailed videos on each one of
these so if you want detailed answers
there's a recent videos about a guy who
asked like prove the quran is from allah
and then hamdally ends up becoming
muslim so you can go see that right
and there is for each one of these that
you mentioned but let's take it one by
one so the first question is how do we
know the quran is from allah
a man named muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him who
could not read or write according to the
consensus of the historians he's unable
to read or write
who had never studied earlier scriptures
who had never studied science who had
never studied philosophy who was not a
poet amongst the arab great poets he was
not a poet
how could he bring forward a quran like
this which no arab poet could respond to
the challenge was put forward bring a
book like it bring this chapter like it
bring certain verses like it they could
not respond how could that be okay maybe
he just got lucky in poetry okay how
could it have scientific facts that were
impossible for a person in that time
frame to have known maybe he guessed
that one okay how did he get repeatedly
every answer right
whether it's the orbits whether it's of
the planetary bodies whether it's the
mixing of salt and sea water whether
it's waves under the ocean every one of
them he gets and got right okay how
would he make prophecies of things to
come like the the victory between the
romans and persians and
consistently get all of those right
even in hadith prophecies that are
coming true in our time how could all of
that come together how could he know
about things in the past that he had no
knowledge of where people would ask him
and then allah would reveal the answer
about for example why was musallam in
misra in the beginning of
surah yusuf this was a question and he
didn't know the answer then allah
revealed it to him right
so putting all of this together we can
say that this man could not have written
or come up with the quran how could a
man like that split the moon can you
split the moon i can't split the moon
there's a video i have that shows you
uh
the
the evidences for the moon spitting and
i think you guys did a reaction to it
masha allah
after that how can you doubt the prophet
of the past
so putting all that together we say no
doubt the quran is from allah first
answer secondly uh was the second why do
we have to do things according to what
the process
yeah
tell you
why do we rely on hadith so
i'll take it i think i'll take them out
of order which is why first thing why do
we even have to follow the way the
prophet salallahu
repeatedly like i said i found this in
different
parts of the quran sometimes like where
it's connected sometimes now but more
than 12 times in the quran allah has
ordered us to follow the prophet
salallahu so that's why we have to
follow the prophet
because allah ordained it
thirdly
why do we have to follow hadith because
how will today we obey the prophet
salallahu for example if i say obey
allah i don't none of you get wahi if
any if you get wahi i'm not going to
podcast with you guys anymore i'm just
kidding right so none of us get wahi we
none of us get revelation right so that
means how do we obey allah we obey the
quran
allah the words of allah
any of you
physically meet the prophet sallam not
in a dream like regularly
if you claim you do then i'm not doing
podcasts
right so if none of us meet the prophet
salallahu physically how will we obey
the prophet
will obey the sunnah say how will you
know what the sunnah is is it is
documented checked and verified in
what's called hadith literature the last
of it being that how do we even know
that this is the thing that
did we have a whole science of checking
a hadith and i have a series of lessons
on it but very briefly we check the
chain of narrators all the way back to
the prophet saws how many people heard
it who they set it to is there any
variation uh how is the memory and
reliability of each one of those
narratives
no science gets checked to the level
that hadith get checked i mean i work in
the med device industry and i can tell
you things that we put out there as
peer-reviewed you know medical journal
entries do not get checked at the level
of what for example
hadith would be checked out
[Music]
they will never truly believe or they
will never be true believers until they
make you referring to the prophet judge
a judge between them and there's their
disputes and find no discontentment or
no discomfort in your decision and
submit for permission and i think
there's another ayah allah
he he says and unparaphrasing again um
that we have sent to you the message so
that you may explain it to them
so alhamdulillah it's very true the the
abdullah the evidence is for following
the sunnah are many imam sheikh
work on this uh many man have written no
doubt to them
okay next question you don't and there's
only two left so you don't have to
answer this if you don't want to because
uh that answer might might be a fitting
go for it
all right i'm not gonna i'm not even
gonna read it bro just if you don't
really read it
and i know fareed and and i i
they're all my brothers in islam um what
i am not going to do is
publicly
now
join a
back and forth with people what i am
doing is and and i have spoken to some
of the brothers that are mentioned here
uh privately
and given my nasiha
and i i'm
i really am glad this question was asked
because i will say this
i call on all of our brothers to
privately talk it out
all of us have mistakes all of us have
shortcomings and
us going back and forth
making videos against each other is
going to do nothing but make the enemies
of islam happy
um
we're all brothers everyone is at a
different level of understanding um uh
sajid masha'allah has studied sharia
mashallah as a graduate
and
masha'allah any
i believe all those brothers ali
muhammad
sajid
and others
are all working towards a good cause
um
some of our brothers are gonna make
mistakes and i understand and some of us
are gonna go about things the wrong way
and i understand
uh
those of us that are
viewing this whether it is just a
regular person on youtube or people like
myself that may personally know them we
should be making dua and trying to make
s between our brothers and trying to
guide our brothers to do things the
right way not flaming this fire i have
not made a video on it on purpose not
that i couldn't have it's not that i
mean i would have got crazy amounts of
views but i didn't because i i don't
think it benefits the dawah and what
benefit are we getting from these videos
back and forth
right
having them i appreciate your question
encourage you matt that i thought i was
going to get attacked for that
all right last question uh
brother shafique writes my question for
the chef is is leasing a quran since
money factor is involved or a better way
to put it is money factor haram when
leasing a car
what's the money factor i'm not really
leasing a car is not haram is no
interest meaning like let's say i come
to you rami and i say hey rami mashallah
would you get that bentley uh your the
the khalil.com must be doing better than
i thought and he's like hey you know
what i'm not going to be using it
because i'm traveling you want to
release it from me and i say okay let me
lease it from you i'll pay you
uh
that's a bentley so i got to pay you a
lot all right uh 2 000 a month is that
cool ronnie can i borrow your bentley
all right so 2 000 a month that's our
deal uh and i'll have it for six months
nothing wrong with that but if leasing
in includes riba like meaning you say
okay
i'll let you lease it for this much but
i'm gonna charge you a percentage
of uh you know
how however you want to shape that ribba
if there's ribba involved then it's not
permissible
okay
uh someone's asking when can we expect
the next q a which man to be
what he said
schedule managers
allow me it's always my pleasure hanging
out with you guys man i love you guys
for the sake of allah i feel very
comfortable with you guys and i
apologize if i get a little uh you know
off scripted but let's just never
apologize for getting too real
alhamdulillah bless you for your work
guys if you made it this far smash the
like button we're going to end the
stream unfortunately but until next time
and please look out for this reaction
video we're going to drop with you with
money been furu on the whole hijab ban
situation in india we don't want to talk
too much about it in this video but
inshallah stay tuned with that it's
going to come in the next few days
insha'allah um and we're going to record
this right now after this live stream
inshallah smash the like button go
follow one message foundation support
the work and rami do you think inshallah
everyone
for your realness because this is
podcast
and with that being s
foreign